[Music]
there's a new airline flying in and out
of reed international we're talking
about brees airways their slogan is
seriously nice the utah-based company
uses new a220 jets that hold 125
passengers jeremy j ford at the airport
today for its inaugural flight
with more than 11 nonstop flights going
in and out of harry reid international
by the end of september brees airlines
is doing their best to leave a footprint
in the commercial airline industry
thursday afternoon more than 50
passengers made the very first flight
into las vegas from richmond virginia
brees airways ceo david nealeyman says
the new airline will allow more
travelers to visit our city our goal is
to get you there for twice as fast for
half the price
and if you can do that then you just
come more often and that's how we build
markets initial flights on brees
airlines include richmond virginia
syracuse new york and fort myers florida
with more destinations to be added in
the upcoming months jeremy j ford live
local now